Hallo. Ich bin Zylal Özçelik Baran. Ich bin als Danner Sinir hier auf dieser Station tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschichte führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache, es guckt jemand auf mich.
Ja, klar.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen stellen möchten, können Sie mir einfach Bescheid geben und können wir ein Pause machen.
Ja, gut.
Ich werde erst ein paar Gemeinnöte stellen und dann wir sprechen über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden.
Okay, fangen wir mal an. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Paul Müller.
Paul Müller. Okay.
Topel L.
Richtig?
Ja, genau.
Paul Müller ist Mann oder Frau?
Er ist ein Mann. Paul ist ein Mann.
Ja, okay, danke schön. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ja, ich bin noch 69. Ich werde dieses Jahr 70.
69.
69, ja.
Ja, okay.
Wann wurden Sie geboren?
Am 18. September 1953.
Ja, danke schön.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin laut Ausweis 174. Ich glaube, das stimmt immer noch.
Ja, okay.
74.
Danke schön. Wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Müller?
83 kg.
Danke schön.
Wie ist Ihr Hausarznehmann?
Das ist Dr. Huber.
Huber.
Okay, danke schön.
Und Herr Müller, was hat Sie uns gebraucht?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe so eine unangenehme Stelle an meinem Bein.
Und zwar unten am Fuß, am rechten,
also innen am Fuß, am Knöchel.
Und ich habe das eigentlich schon ziemlich länger.
Das ist schon eine ganze Weile, aber jetzt wird es mit einmal immer größer und immer tiefer.
Und da kommt jetzt auch so komische Flüssigkeit raus.
Und das läuft richtig runter.
Und das ist mir jetzt doch ein bisschen unheimlich.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, jetzt muss ich da doch mal hinkommen,
bevor ich da irgendwelche großen Schwierigkeiten bekomme.
Ja, und das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Und wann haben Sie diese Wischwerden?
Also das, was jetzt so nässt und auch so größer geworden ist, merke ich eigentlich erst,
dass da Flüssigkeit raus ist, erst seit ein paar Tagen, seit drei, vier Tagen.
Und da habe ich dann eben auch nochmal wieder richtig genau hingeguckt.
Und dann habe ich auch gemerkt, dass die Stelle auch größer geworden ist.
Und das ist auch so, dass das ganze Bein eigentlich so ein bisschen geschwollen ist.
Und ich habe so, wenn man geguckt, die Haut ist auch so komisch dunkel verfärbt.
Das sieht alles nicht schön aus.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Und wo genau diese Wischwerden?
Sie sagen rechten Fuß und rechten Bein, oder?
Am rechten Bein und zwar innen am Knöchel.
Innen am Knöchel, ja.
Okay.
Und strahlen diese geschwollen aus in irgendwelche Regionen?
Die Schmerzen strahlen bis in den Unterschenkel rein, merke ich.
Unterschenken, ja, okay.
Sie haben auch Beinschmerzen.
Ja, also eigentlich sitzt es im Knöchel, diese Stelle, aber das strahlt bis ins Bein rein, ja.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Okay, und wann dann die Schmerzen oder Bechwerden an irgendwelche Körperregionen?
Die wandern, nein, die sind immer da in Beinen.
Ja, okay.
Und könnten Sie diese Beinschmerzen beschreiben?
Genau, ich meine, die sind in der Hand, in der Brennende oder in der Seehende.
Also das ist so ein typischer Wunschmerz, so stechen Brennen beschreibt das schon ganz gut, ja.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt oder?
Ein Unfall, nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste, ich hatte keine Unfall gehabt.
Haben Sie geschwürzt?
Was habe ich?
Geschwürzt.
Ein Geschwür?
Ja.
Und wie verhalten sich die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit?
Also es geht eigentlich ein bisschen besser, wenn ich den Fuß nicht belaste und wenn ich die Beine hochlege, habe ich das Gefühl, dass es dann ein bisschen besser wird.
Aber gerade wenn ich morgens aufstehe oder auch wenn ich nachts mal auf die Toilette muss, dann habe ich immer das Gefühl, das schießt so richtig rein und schmerzt.
Okay.
Und wie stark die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wenn 1 leichter, 10 sehr starker Schmerzen sind?
Wie schätzen Sie ein?
Normalerweise kann ich das ja aushalten, ein bisschen weh tut es natürlich immer, da ist es vielleicht so bei 3, 4, aber wenn das dann mal so einschießt oder wenn ich ein Stück laufe, dann habe ich das Gefühl, auch wenn ich dagegen stoße ausversehen, wenn ich da irgendwo mal dagegen komme mit dem Schuh oder so, dann sind die Schmerzen deutlich mehr.
Ja, okay.
Und wie haben die Beschwerden, ich meine, geschwollen begonnen?
Ja, das ist schon langsam.
Es war eine kleine Stelle und ja, das habe ich eigentlich nicht so ernst genommen, dann hat das mal ein bisschen geblutet, dann habe ich da Flasser drauf gemacht und dann war es wieder, da war eine Kruste drauf und ja, und jetzt ist es mit einmal eben so groß geworden und jetzt ist es eben so, dass es so ähnlich ist, dass da so Flüssigkeit austritt.
Okay. Und wie haben Sie Herzschmerzen oder Herzkrankheiten?
Also ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, aber sonst habe ich eigentlich keine Herzschmerzen.
Und wie viel Meter laufen Sie ohne Schmerzen zu bekommen?
Das kann ich gar nicht so genau sagen. Also ich habe gar nicht so viel zu gehen, ich bin halt zu Hause und versorgen meine Ehefrau und sie sitzt im Rollstuhl und da haben wir nie so riesige Strecken, die wir zurückliegen.
Aber eigentlich kann ich schon ein Stück laufen, aber jetzt in den letzten Tagen fällt mir das schon eher schwer.
Da würde ich vielleicht sagen, dass das dann irgendwie so nach einem Kilometer oder so unangenehm wird.
Ja, okay, haben Sie Hautausschlag bemeint?
Ja, die Haut nicht so richtig in den Ausschlagen, sondern eher so, dass das ganze Bein so ein bisschen bläulich verfärbt ist.
Und haben Sie noch etwas bemerkt an Betroffenen bei?
An den Beinen, nur nü, das reicht mir völlig, die Probleme, die ich da habe.
Okay. Und haben Sie erbrochen?
Ob ich erbrochen habe, nur habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig? Nein, normal nicht.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Und ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, ich habe Schmerzen in meinen Beinen.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe aber ich muss das fragen.
Das gehört unsere Gespräche, deswegen frage ich Sie.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht.
Meistens ist es einfach kalt, wenn man Fieber hat.
Ich habe einen heißen Kopf, aber habe ich jetzt nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie Säckernbiss gehabt?
Ein Zeckebiss?
Ja.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin zwar manchmal draußen im Park spazieren, aber wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Also ich habe das nicht bemerkt auf alle Dinge.
Ja, okay.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich versorg meine Ehefrau, die im Rollstuhl sitzt.
Und da kommen wir gar nicht so weit.
Haben Sie Gefässerkrankungen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Sitten bemerkt?
Sitten?
Ja.
Ich zitter nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bewegungseinschränkungen bemerkt?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich schwohn das Bein jetzt, weil es weh tut.
Deswegen bewege ich das nicht so viel.
Wenn man normalerweise mit dem anderen Fuß kann,
kann ich mit dem Knöchel so rumdrehen.
Das würde ich jetzt da nicht machen,
weil ich das Gefühl hätte, die Haut tut weh.
Ja, okay.
Ich verstehe.
Und fühlen Sie sich wärmer als sonst an Ihrer Bein?
Ob das Bein wärmer ist?
Ja, wärmer.
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Das ist so ein bisschen geschwollen, habe ich den Eindruck.
Im Vergleich.
Aber so ein bisschen gespannt.
Aber wärmer ist mir jetzt nicht aufmerksam.
Oder kalter?
Kalter Gefühl habe ich Sie?
Ne.
Eine Kälter fühlt sich das nicht an.
Okay.
Und wie beschreiben Sie diese Ausruf oder Ausscheidung?
Haben Sie eine Parkterrenderung bemerkt?
Oder Eiter oder Blutig?
Das, was da hier draus kommt, diese Flüssigkeit.
Das ist so ein hellbräuliches, gelbliches Zeugen,
das da auch aufhängt.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Ich schlafe nicht mehr so gut, was auch natürlich damit zusammenhängt,
dass ich zwischendurch auch noch meine Frau gucken muss.
Und wenn sie etwas braucht, muss ich mich halt kümmern.
Also ich schlafe nicht so sehr gut.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Apathit?
Was eigentlich, kann ich nicht klagen.
Mir schmeckt es auch nicht schon gut.
Okay.
Und ich möchte fragen,
haben Sie ein Herzrasen oder Perpetation oder Taubheit gefühlt?
Ja, ich habe ein Herzrasen,
und ich habe ein Taubheitsgefühl.
Also manchmal hat man ja so das Gefühl,
wenn eine Wunde zuhaltet ist,
dass es so ein bisschen dückt.
Aber so richtiges Kribbeln,
wenn man auf der Hand eingeschlafen ist,
so etwas habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang?
Also haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, also in meinem Alter,
da muss man nachts schon mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Und ich habe auch Probleme mit Verstock vor.
Verstock.
Okay.
Ich habe auch Probleme mit Verstock vor.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Ja, schon eigentlich jahrelang würde ich sagen.
Verstärkt wahrscheinlich seit ich nicht mehr rauche.
Mit dem Rauchen kann man immer gut auf die Toilette gehen,
aber ich rauche jetzt seit 18 Jahren nicht mehr.
Und ich glaube, so lange habe ich auch schon diese Probleme.
Und wie verhalten Sie sich mehr beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, ich glaube,
ich habe das schon lange nicht mehr.
Und wie ist die Schmerz beim Hochlagerung?
Dann habe ich das Gefühl,
wenn ich das, also das ist ein bisschen angenehmer.
Angenehmer.
Und sind Sie beim Stechen bleiben,
diese Schmerzen verstärkt?
Wenn ich stehe und gehe und belaste,
habe ich das Gefühl, die Schmerz ist verstärkt.
Ja, in Ruhe hätten Sie verbessert.
Okay.
Und Hochlagerung, das funktioniert nicht angenehm.
Ein bisschen angenehm.
Danke schön.
Und leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, wie gesagt, der Blutbruch unter 10 Jahren.
Ja, außer Bluthochdruck.
Und ich habe,
ja, ich höre ein bisschen schlechten,
habe deswegen Höhrgeräte.
Und da hatte ich jetzt,
eigentlich seit Jahren habe ich immer wieder
so eine Mittelohrenzündung.
Das kommt immer wieder.
Und zuletzt hatte ich davor 3 Wochen Schwierigkeiten.
Und dann wird das behandelt
und dann geht das mir wieder besser.
Okay, super.
Und noch etwas?
Ne, sonst eigentlich so vorherkrankt.
Ist das noch interessant?
Ich hatte vor 5 Jahren mal eine Trombose im rechten Bein.
Rechte Bein.
Okay.
Okay, und hatten Sie, hatten Sie ein,
ein Brustprobleme, Brusterkrankungen?
Bist du nicht?
Ja, also, was kann?
Urmönerödem, Entzündung oder, oder was?
Was habe ich?
Lungenerkrankungen.
Eine Lungenerkrankung?
Nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Und nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme Zofenopril
und HTT 25.
25.
Ja, okay.
Und wie oft am Abend oder morgen?
Zofenopril nehme ich morgens und abends
und HTT nehme ich eine morgens.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Zofenopril, 2 Mal pro Tag.
2 Mal am Tag, einmal morgens, einmal abends
und HTT einmal morgens.
Ja, einmal morgens.
Und die viel Milligramm wissen Sie?
HTT ist 25.
Okay, noch etwas?
Und dann nehme ich noch aspirin, eine am Tag.
Aspirin.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ja, diese aspirin ist 100.
Okay.
Was man so als Dauermedikament bekommt.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und würden Sie schon einmal
schon einmal behandelt
oder operiert?
Operiert?
Nein, ich war wegen der Urne,
aber sonst habe ich noch nie eine Operation.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Allergie gegen etwas
oder Unverträglichkeit gegen Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich darf kein Fisch
und keine Meeresfrüchte essen.
Also auch keine Krammen
oder irgendwie Hummer oder so etwas Tolles.
Also Meeresfrüchte kann ich nicht essen.
Und bei bestimmten Handcremes
kriege ich so einen Hautausschlag,
dass sich die Haut sich
ganz stark verschlechtert
und dass ich so juckende Pickel kriege.
Und ich habe auch ein Hautausschlag.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Wie ist Ihr im Status?
Also gegen Corona bin ich natürlich geimpft.
Ja, super.
Und Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Und rauchen Sie Hämula?
Ich rauch seit 18 Jahren nicht mehr,
aber davor habe ich natürlich ganz schön geraucht.
Okay.
Und was haben Sie geraucht?
Zigaretten.
Und wie lange haben Sie geraucht
und wie oft pro Tag?
Wie viel pro Tag?
Ja, ich habe schon ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht
und über 30 Jahre.
Ja, über 30 Jahre.
Okay, aber das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Ja, da bin ich auch voll mit dem Motor übergegen.
Ja, sehr gut für Blütehoch zurück.
Super, gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol. Ich trinke hin und wieder ein Bier.
Ja, ziemlich regelmäßig.
Und ich habe auch eine Flasche,
eine Flasche, eine Flasche Bier am Arbeit.
Danke schön.
Und Hämula, das ist eine Routine Frage.
Ich muss das fragen, bitte nehmen Sie persönlich.
Nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Oder haben Sie es nochmal probiert?
Also außer Alkohol und Drogen
haben wir ja auch Alkohol und rauchen.
Ja, super.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Noch einmal im Alter, da ist das nicht mehr so.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Familienstadt? Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, dachte ich.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder und ein Enkelkind.
Ja, super.
Kinder gesund?
Ja, die sind alle gesund.
Okay.
Und wie sind Sie vom Büro?
Ich bin reichner jetzt.
Hab ich verstanden.
Ich bin Rentner.
Und wer waren Sie vom Büro?
Was? Ja, ich war angesteuert in der Verwaltung.
Ja, Angesteuerte.
Super.
Und Herr Müller, ich möchte das fragen.
Leben Ihre Familien noch?
Also meine Familie, meine Frau, meine Kinder leben alle ja?
Nein, ich meine Mutter und Vater.
Nein, gucken Sie mal wie alt ich bin.
Ich bin ja schon fast 70.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich bin ja schon seitdem in der Verwaltung.
Ich habe meine Eltern nicht mehr in einem Leben.
Ja, ich weiß.
Aber ich möchte nicht sein.
Und deswegen habe ich gefragt.
Und woran und wann Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Ja, also ich weiß,
dass mein Vater irgendwie eine Krebserkrankung hatte.
Der hatte in den Gallengängen.
Irgendwann hatte der ein Tumor.
Und dann ist er da dran gestorben.
Und dann wurde er über die Darmprobleme,
was da genau war, weiß ich auch nicht.
Die hat dann noch von künstlichen Darmausgang bekommen.
Und ist aber dann auch vor kurzem verstorben.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Danke schon Herr Müller.
Also wir sind jetzt am Ende unseres Geschipel.
Danke schön für Ihre Mitarbeiter.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder was?
Ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Ihnen noch etwas Neues erzählen kann.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Herr Müller, ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich aninterzieren und natürlich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und dann werde ich eine Duplexsonografie veranlassen.
Was ist das?
Was ist eine Duplexsonografie?
Ja, Duplexsonografie.
Duplexsonografie ist eine Ultraschallmethode,
aber Ultraschall ist natürlich nicht invasive,
schmerzfrei untersucht.
Das ist gut, wenn es so wieht.
Und das ist risikolos, beruhigen Sie sich und Sie haben kein Angst machen.
Und natürlich mit dieser Untersuchung
geschehen wir die Flüssigkeit in Ihre Gefäße, also ich meine Blut.
Und ja, wir beurteilen mit Hilfe dieser Methode
Blutflüssigkeit oder Blutrichtung, oder gibt es eine Verrängung?
Das war gut, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ich habe Kollegen und Kollegen in anderen Fragen.
Ich musste einen Anruf tätigen, könnte ich nicht so hören, es tut mir leid.
Und deswegen, welche Fragen fällt.
Aber eigentlich glaube ich, Sie hat wirklich sehr komplett durchgehend alles gefragt.
Und das sehen wir gleich bei der Präsentation, wenn Frau Bahran das Arztgespräch führt,
wenn sie dann irgendwas fehlt.
Aber ich glaube, Sie hat wirklich sehr vollständig alles gefragt.
Ja, danke.
Könnten wir Arztheizgespiele anfangen?
Ja, okay.
Ein bisschen zu zerstreiten, ne?
Ja, ich muss drucken.
Können wir eben eine Minute, dass Sie einmal Ihre Sache druckieren?
Ja, okay, super.
Du viel Zeit muss sein.
Auslöser gefragt?
Ja, ich habe gefragt.
Aber keine Auslöser, aber Sie sagten in Belastung in Stähen verschlechtert und in Ruhe verbessert.
Die Schmerzen.
Ja, die Schmerzen.
Aber, also, wann das aufgetreten ist, es ist langsam, hat irgendwann, war eine kleine Stelle da
und die war über viele Monate da.
Und hat man nicht so ernst genommen und jetzt ist sie mit einmal vergrößert und auch zunehmend schmerzhaft.
Ernste Beschwerden hat gefragt.
Ernste Beschwerden.
Ja, ja, sie hat gefragt.
Ihre Bein geschwollt und gerötet und war...
Es ist blau, es ist nicht rot, es ist blau verfärbt.
Ja, richtig.
Blaulich, oder?
Ja, blaulich verfärbt.
Warn, fühlen Sie sich, warn ihre Beine?
Das hat sie gefragt.
Ja.
Keine, keine, also keine übermäßige Wärme und auch kein kältiges Bild.
Offene Wunde, keine?
Doch, natürlich.
Deswegen ist er da.
Wegen der offenen Wunde ist er da.
Eine offene Stelle am Bein.
Offene Stelle gibt es offene Stelle?
Ja, deswegen ist der Patient in die Klinik gekommen, weil die offene Stelle größer geworden ist und tiefer und weil sie jetzt näht.
Das ist der Anlass für seine Vorstellung.
Der Patient hat beschreiben diese Wunde.
Er hat den, also von der Ausdehnung hatte sie nicht geschrieben?
Nein, ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Ich habe keine näheren Informationen.
Also ich denke mal, es ist eben eine sich vergrößernde Hautläsion, die eben jetzt anfängt zu messen.
Und ob jetzt die Rundränder gelblich belegt sind oder so genau hat er sich das nicht angeguckt.
Eidlich, eidlich, hat der Patient gesagt.
Hat er nicht gesagt?
Nein, das ist Missverständnis.
Nein, das ist Flüssigkeit.
Was?
Flüssigkeit.
Ich habe gesagt, freundliche Flüssigkeit wird aus.
Ja, ja, verstehe.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich kann nicht eine Flüssigkeit, ich kann nicht eine Flüssigkeit,
ich kann nicht eine Flüssigkeit, ich kann nicht eine Flüssigkeit,
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich kann nicht eine genaue Diagnose stellen.
Ja, verstehe ich mich.
Ja, wir kommen mal, nicht?
Ich komme mal, dass rauskommt, ja.
Die Züge, die Züge.
Okay.
Torbarai Türk bitte, aber die ja Missin, ich bin.
Ja.
Ich bin, ich bin.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Man muss eine Diagnose machen und dann muss man Differenzialdiagnose machen.
Ja, okay.
Und entweder stimmt die Hauptdiagnose und die Differenzialdiagnose entfallen
oder eine von den Differenzialdiagnosen ist es.
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht gehört, ihre Wunde, wo genau?
In welchen Richtesbeinen?
Rechtesbein.
Rechtesbein, wo?
Innenknöchel.
Innenknöchel des rechten Beines.
Sie haben gesagt, keine Unfall gehabt.
Kein Unfall.
Schussunfall gibt es, ihre Schuss, Eikabun.
Ein Schussunfall?
Schuhe.
Ach, eine Scheuerstelle von den Schuhen.
Ach, so was, okay.
Es ist ihm nicht aufgefallen.
Also, ne?
Ja.
Zeig dir eure Füße, zeig dir eure Schuhe.
Es gibt so ein Kinderlied.
Ja, okay.
Empangen.
Ja.
Gut.
Okay.
Ich bin nicht genug, aber ja.
Ja, versuchen wir.
Wir versuchen unser Bestes.
Ja, natürlich.
Hallo Frau Doktor, ich habe heute einen Patient um Sie vorzustellen.
dürfen wir anfangen?
Ja, natürlich.
Den haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, danke schön.
Herr Müller ist neun, sechstisjährige Patientin, der sich heute Morgen bei uns wegen
der Schmerzen und Flüssigkeit vorgestellt hat.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den Schmerzen
in den Schmerzen, in den Schmerzen, in den Schmerzen
vorgestellt haben.
Und er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den Schmerzen
in den ganz rechten Beinen ausgeschritten haben.
Er hat in Wirklichkeit, hat er gesagt, die Strahle in den Unterschenkel aus.
Unterschenkel, ja, ja, ja.
Unterschenkel aus.
Und der Patient berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in Ruhe verbessert
und in Belastung und im Stähnen verschlechtert hätten.
Nein.
Ja.
In Ruhe nicht.
Nein, Hochlage, ja.
Also ohne Belastung und Hochlage, ob es besser.
Ja, okay, aber Sie haben mir gesagt,
bei Hochlage genug, ich fühle angenehme Gefühle.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt besser geworden.
Ja, besser geworden, ja, das ist gut.
Ja, super, okay.
Und der Patient berichtet, dass die Flüssigkeit farbe ist,
dunkler und blaulich sein.
Die Flüssigkeit ist blaulich?
Ich rechte Bein komplett, sieh an oder sieh an.
Ja, okay, ich rechte.
Und der Patient hatte diese Beschwerden lange,
aber innerhalb drei oder vier Tagen ziemlich lange war man
und immer grosser geschwollen, gesagt.
Ja, der ist stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, aber da müssen wir jetzt mal
eben, bevor wir das ganz aus den Augen verlieren.
Sie haben ganz am Anfang gesagt, der sich vorstellt wegen,
und da haben Sie gesagt, wegen kurz, also seit drei Tagen
bestehender, schmerzender und nennsender Out-Veränderung
am Bein.
Und das stimmt ja nicht.
Was Sie jetzt sagen ist richtig, dass er das schon seit Monaten hat
und dass er aber jetzt eine massive Verschlechterung erlebt.
Ja, okay.
Ja, jetzt ist eine massive Verschlechterung und die letzten
Monate hatte er schon diese offene Stelle und hat das aber
bagatellisiert eigentlich.
Ja, okay.
Und jetzt ist es schlimmer geworden und seit neuestem tritt eben
die Aufmerksamkeit aus.
Ja, okay.
Ich wusste es nicht, was ich sagen würde.
Sie haben es jetzt geschehen, ne?
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Und die Fragen, Taubheitgefühl, Krippen oder Gewinne,
Ab- oder Zunahme oder Reiseanamnese,
Sekkenbis, wurde von dem Patient, bei dem Patient verneint
und der Patient sagte uns, Sie fühlen nicht warme
oder kalter in Bein.
Also das Bein ist nicht überwärmt und es fühlt sich auch nicht kräter an.
Ja.
Und noch etwas, genau nicht den Unfall.
Der Patient hatte keine Unfall.
Er hatte keine Unfall?
Ja.
Und die Fragen nach Emesis oder Schwindelich oder
Übel von dem Patient verneint.
Ja, können wir da eben auch noch eben schnell sprechen,
nach Schwindel oder Übelkeit.
Nicht schwindelig, schwindelig ist das Adjektiv,
Schwindel ist das Nomen.
Und Übel ist das Adjektiv und Übelkeit ist das Nomen.
Die Frage nach Schwindel oder Übelkeit wurde vereint.
Und der Patient war bei Bewegung geschränkt wegen der Me,
wegen Bein oder Me.
Also und er habe keine Fieber und er habe Schlafstörungen
wegen Schmerzen und ihr Appetit ist normal.
Und sie klagt über Nekturi und Verstopfung.
Ja, immer noch ein Mann, Herr Müller.
Ja, Herr Müller.
Okay, danke schön.
Und sie leide an Arterialhypertonie seit 10 Jahren
und er habe Hörgerate und er hatte mehrmals Autitis-Media gelitten.
Super, ja.
Okay, und er habe an rechten Beintrombose vor 4 und 5 Jahren
und er nehme regelmäßig Souffé No Pyril,
25 Milligramm am Abend und am Morgen ein
und hc t 20 Milligramm am Abend und am Morgen.
Und...
No am Morgen, ne?
Souffé No Pyril, 5 und 25 Milligramm.
Ja, okay.
Und er nehme auch Aspirin einmal täglich ein
und er wurde vor 3 Wochen wegen Mittelloren und Autitis-Media behandelt
und er wurde keine Operation durchgeführt.
Es wurde im Volkali-Operation durchgeführt.
Und er habe mehrere frische Allergie.
Also mehrere Produkte.
Mehrere Strüchte, ja.
Ja, okay. Ich meinte, Fischprodukte.
Ja, Fischprodukte.
Ja, und alles, was sonst mehr gibt.
Ja, keine Muskeln kann.
Ja, okay.
Und er reagiert darauf, Hautauschlag und Schuken
und er im Status sei komplett, oder ist komplett
und er habe ein Päckchen Zigaretze,
war 3 Jahren geraucht, aber...
30 Jahre.
Ja, okay.
Das ist ein Unterschied.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe 30 geschrieben, aber 3 gesagt.
Ja, okay.
Und er habe kein Zigaretze, 8 oder 10 Jahre geraucht.
Seit 18 Jahren ist er nicht raucher.
Seit 18 Jahren nicht 8 oder 10, seit 18 Jahren.
Okay.
Okay, danke.
Und er trinkt am Abend ein Flaschebierer.
Ein Flaschebierer.
Ja, und er konsumiert keine Drogen.
Er ist verheiratet und er habe 2 Kinder
und ein Enkel, 2 gesunde Kinder
und er ist Rentner und er habe als Angestellte gearbeitet,
früher, und Familienanamnese,
ja Mutter,
an Darmprobleme küsstischen,
ein Darmprobleme gestorben
und ihre Mutter hatte küsstischen Darmprobleme, ja.
Könnte ich ihn da auch ausgehen?
Wie heißt das denn aus?
Ja, Gastro-Toni oder...
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie das.
Anus Mond.
Anus Fräter.
Ja, ich glaube, ihre Mutter hat eine Krebs oder was,
seine Mutter.
Seine Mutter.
Seine Vater.
Seine Vater an.
Sein Vater?
Sein Vater an.
Ja, okay.
Ange Krebs gestorben.
Und er habe keine Geschwester.
Ja, das war es.
Ja, also Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja, also am nächtlichen Angaben deuten am Ehesten auf,
wenn es Öze effizient sind für mich,
als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen in Poligende Betra,
Corona Herzkrankheit und Unfall.
Ich habe ein Borrelia.
Borrelia und noch was.
Und PAVK oder?
Ja, gut.
Was macht dir das mit den Patienten?
Ja, ich würde den Patienten eine Doppler-Stonografie veranlassen.
Was erwarten Sie?
Ich erwarte ein Verstopfung in den Venen-Gepäße.
Ah, genau.
Also ein Venöse ist ein Problem.
Ja, genau.
Aber wie nennen wir das denn,
wenn durch eine Venöse Insuffizienz
eine offene Stelle entstanden ist?
Wie heißt das denn?
Also das ist ein Gangrene.
Das ist eigentlich eher bei PAVK.
Ich habe geschrieben, Ulcus curris.
Ulcus curris.
Genau.
Ulcus curris, Venosum wäre unsere Hauptdiagnose.
Was man auch noch überlegen müsste,
der hat zwar keine Hinweise darauf gegeben,
aber manchmal bleibt es ja auch lange unentdeckt.
Das ist eine diabetese Fußerkrankung.
Das muss man da jetzt auf die Zucker werden.
Was machen Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Worauf achten Sie denn da?
Sie machen ja nicht gleich als erstes das Doplex,
sondern erst mal die allgemeine körperliche Untersuchung.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Ich würde natürlich erst vital sein.
Also Ulz gemessen, Herzfrequenz gemessen,
Atemfrequenz gemessen, Blutdruck gemessen, das kann sein.
Weil der Patient, der Arterialhypertone,
habe seit zehn Jahren deswegen.
Und noch etwas.
Und Fieber gemessen, natürlich.
Was machen Sie denn mit Ihren Augen?
Worauf gucken Sie denn?
Ichterus, ich kann.
Ja, warum soll denn ichterus haben?
Was gucken Sie denn erst mal das Bein an?
Ja, geschwollen.
Ja, und sich das mal gucken.
Wie groß ist die Wunde?
Blutet das?
Wie sieht dieses Sequet aus, was da runterläuft?
Gut, wie sind die Wunden Ränder?
Sind die gleichmäßig oder sind die unregelmäßig?
Ist die Wunde belegt oder ist die sauber?
Wie hat er die überhaupt verbunden?
Was hat er da draufgepackt?
Hat er das Leukoplasflasser draufgeklebt?
Oder hat er da ein Handtuch drum gewickelt?
Wie sieht die Verpackung von der ganzen Geschichte aus?
Sie gucken sich das Ganze an.
Sie gucken vielleicht nach einem denkbaren Ideen.
Sie gucken das Hautkolorit an.
Und Sie vergleichen auch das Rechte und das linke Bein.
Ja, natürlich.
Sie müssen die linke Bein und die rechte Bein vergleichen.
Vergleiten, genau.
Und dann würde man als nächstes Jahr diese Kompassons- und Duplex-Solografie machen.
Was würde man denn dann noch machen?
Ja, also gegebenenfalls würde ich eine Angiografie machen.
Aber erst mal nehmen Sie den Patienten doch Blut ab.
Ja, ja, ja.
Welche Blutwerte, welche Laborwerte bestimmen Sie denn?
Ja, Zucker, Blutzucker und Blutbild natürlich.
Und einstündig Parameter, natürlich sehr wichtig.
Und noch etwas, mein Sohn.
Der hat erzählt, dass er mal eine tiefe Windromose hatte.
Ja, und die Daimers.
Die Daimers, ja, wurde.
Die Rinnungen könnte man nochmal gucken.
Ja, und BCG, natürlich.
Und dann, was würden Sie im Labor denn möglicherweise noch untersuchen?
Okay, was meinen Sie? Labor.
Ja, was könnte man in dem Labor noch zukommen lassen an Arbeit?
Was könnte man noch machen, wenn man eine offene Wunder hat?
Ja, okay. Wunder.
Okay.
Wunder.
Abschritte, ja, genau.
Und da ist eigentlich, weiß gar nicht, das Thema müsste eigentlich ja immer noch in allen Köpfen,
sehr aktuell sein trotz Corona, dass man eigentlich
schon im Vorfeld gucken müsste, ob der Patient im Nasenrachenabstrich MRSA hat.
Okay.
Zumal der seine pflegebedürftige Ehefrau pflegt.
Das ist ja heutzutage einer der problematischen Geschichten,
dass viele Ulkospatienten eben mit Belicken, also mit MRSA, initiiert sind
und dass man dann der Geschichte sehr schlecht her wird.
Also, ein MRSA, strich sollte man auf alle Fälle machen
und sonst auch gucken, was da sonst so wechseln in den Dingen.
Gut.
Ja.
Okay.
Und, was wäre denn die Therapien, wenn der Patient tatsächlich ein genüses Ulkos hat?
Ja. Okay.
Also, erste Lebensstilveränderung, das kann sein.
Ja, ich meine, ich meine, Blutdruck einstellen.
Ja, aber der Blutdruck macht ja eigentlich kein Ulkos, ne?
Ja, okay.
Und Wundversorgung.
Die Wundversorgung macht erstes, genau.
Antibiotikum.
Ja, und eben die passende, was für eine Wundauflage tut man denn auf
eine nessende Wunde?
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Also, ich gebe eine Antibiotikum nach die Befunde.
Ja, also nach Abstrichbefunden, ne?
Also, nach Antibiogramm, kann man machen, ja?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Und hoffen wir, dass es kein MRSA ist, ne?
Ja.
Ja, aber Sie müssen ja, wenn es eine stark nessende Wunde ist,
müssen Sie ja eine flüssigkeitsaufsorgende,
eine flüssigkeitsaufsorgende Wundauflage haben, ne?
Und was ist dann immer noch die Therapie?
Was muss man unbedingt noch machen?
Antibiotikum und, ja, Kleksan oder was?
Je nachdem, wenn der noch irgendwelche Trombosezeichen hat,
aber eigentlich ist davon ja nicht die Rede.
Ne, was macht man denn, wie behandelt man denn das Unkoschkores
außer mit der Wundauflage?
Antibiotikum und Person.
Ne, nicht nur Antibiotik, was machen Sie noch?
Was machen Sie?
Also Sauerstofftherapie, wissen Sie?
Das gibt es auch, ja, bei ganz schweren Fällen kann man das machen, ja?
Das meine ich aber nicht.
Das ist eine ganz ordinäre Methode,
wie Nöselkrankungen behandelt werden.
Eigentlich der Goldstahner, was macht man?
Was kriegt der Patient im Krankenhaus zur Profilaxe einer Trombose?
Was kriegt der Patient da?
Pardon?
Und?
Kleksan.
Markumarsch.
Ne, ich mag nicht.
Was kriegt der noch?
Markumarsch.
Nein, das sind ja alles Medikamente.
Was kriegt der noch?
Er kriegt noch Strümpfe an.
Ja, wer je eine kleine Operation hatte,
erinnert sich bestens an die prima weißen Strümpfe, die man trägt.
Ja.
Und unsere Patienten mit dem Ulcus müssen natürlich auch
einen Kompression haben.
Ja, so, bis der Kompressionstrumpf angepasst wird,
werden die Beine gewickelt.
Ja.
Ja, hier gibt es einen schönen elastischen Verband.
Ja, und dann werden die Beine gewickelt.
Ich würde sagen, mein Vater leidet an Benösinspezias.
Ja, also, der Mann zu.
Ja, er tragt.
Er muss Strümpfe tragen, ne?
Er tragt nicht Strümpfe, deswegen muss man ihn auf die Finger klopfen.
Ja.
Wenn keine Strümpfe trägt, ne?
Das ist Mist.
Ja, man muss Strümpfe tragen.
Kompression ist das A und O.
Auch wenn viele glauben das ja nicht.
Viele Patienten glauben, ja,
muss doch Luft an die Beine dran, ja?
Nein, es muss die Kompression damit der Druck von innen weggeht.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Ja, das ist ein ganz anderer Teil.
Ja, gut.
Also, der Patient braucht Kompression Strümpfe
und er braucht eine vernünftige Mundbehandlung darunter.
Und dann muss man gucken,
wenn der jetzt tatsächlich eine Benusinsuffizienz hat,
kann man dann immer noch überlegen,
ob man die Intifiziente Wehne behandelt
oder ob man da vielleicht mit einer Sklerotherapie was machen kann.
Dass man die verödet.
Ja, das Ding,
das Ding, was dieses Urkust speist,
dass das eben verödet wird oder ausgeschaltet wird.
Und dann hat das auch eine Chance, abzuheilen.
Denn, was passiert,
wenn wir diesen Patienten hier keine suficiente Therapie geben?
Was passiert dann?
Also, ja, ich würde einen Ekokardiograph veranstalten.
Was passiert, wenn wir diesen Patienten
keine angemessene Therapie für sein Urkust geben?
Ja, das kann gangrein vergesachen.
Ja, also das wird immer größer, immer tiefer.
Ja.
Und dann wird es immer schwieriger,
so eine Mundentzunge verschlusszubringen.
Ja.
Dann hat der Ewigkeiten mit einer auch in größen Wunde zu tun.
Gut, das wollen wir nicht.
Deswegen, ja, am schlimmsten Falle amputation.
Ja, gut.
Gut, also, ich glaube, wir kommen zum Schluss.
Ja, ihre Analyse war ja ganz gut, muss man sagen.
Da haben sie sich ja wacker geschlagen.
Sie haben konsequent ihre Fragen gestellt,
wobei ich als Patient ja schon ein bisschen ungehalten reagiert habe,
als sie mich nach so etwas wie Verdauung und Herz gefragt haben.
Ja.
Und so, da habe ich dann, oder Übelkeit, da habe ich ja gesagt,
hey, was wollen Sie eigentlich von mir?
Ich habe es doch am Bein, nicht hier oben,
sondern da unten ist das Problem.
Ja, aber ich habe dann natürlich irgendwann geschnallt,
es geht Ihnen um die Borreliose.
Ja, da wollten Sie drauf.
Und wollten nachhauchen, ob der Patient eben irgendwelche anderen Geschichten hat.
Ja, so.
Gut, also, das, insofern muss man da eben auch damit rechnen,
dass der Patient auch mal so ein bisschen ungehalten wird
und sagt, ah, was fragen Sie mich eigentlich alles?
Ja.
Ja, das hat das mit meinem Fuß zu tun.
Ja, gut.
Und formal war es eben ganz am Anfang,
das habe ich aber schon reklamiert,
dass sie gesagt haben,
er stellt sich wegen eines akutaufgetretenen,
sperrzhaften Ställe und nessenen Ställe vor.
Nein, das ist eben eine akutverschlechterte,
aber schon lange bestehende.
Das ist ein Unterschied.
Seit wann besteht etwas?
Ja, also die Wunde bestand schon lange,
hat sich aber in den letzten Tagen akut verschlechtert.
Okay.
Das sind die Faktive.
Ja, okay.
Und wichtig ist eben, er hat ja gesagt, ich habe eine offene Stelle.
Das ist eine offene Runde.
Sie haben ihn irgendwann mal gefragt,
haben Sie, was haben Sie gefragt?
Haben Sie ein Gespür?
Was weiß der Patient, was ein Gespür ist?
Er hat eine offene Stelle.
Das ist ein Gespür, natürlich.
Ja, okay.
Ja, so.
Dann, ja, und dann haben Sie ja hinterher praktisch erzählt,
dass er die Schmerzen schon, die Stelle schon länger hat.
Und da bin ich eingestiegen und habe ihm gesagt,
nee, also so war es nicht.
Das war so lange und es hat sich jetzt verschlechtert.
Und eben, dass da eine Flüssigkeit austritt.
Ja, das war für ihn eigentlich so ein Anlass zu sagen,
jetzt muss ich aber mal was machen.
Solange das alles schön friedlich war,
hat er sich die Wunde nicht näher angeguckt.
Und jetzt hat er gemerkt,
das wird ja nass unangenehm.
Dann muss man was tun.
Ja, irgendwas habe ich mir aufgeschrieben.
Es sind noch so ein paar grammatikalische Geschichten drin.
Wie immer.
Dann ich mache.
Werb und zweiter Stelle immer wieder da selbe, dann mache ich.
Und als ich irgendwie,
ich weiß gar nicht, an welcher Stelle,
irgendwann haben wir, Sie haben keine Angst machen.
Also, nein, das geht natürlich nicht.
Sie müssen sich keine Sorgen,
Sie müssen keine Angst haben,
oder machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Und ja, was mir aufgefallen ist sprachlich.
Das war auch ein bisschen die alte Leier.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Anamnesen Sie schon mitgehört haben.
Ich sage das ungefähr jedes zweite Mal.
Haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie.
Das ist sterbenlangweilig zum Zugucken.
Ja, haben Sie verschiedene Sachen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen das?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Haben Sie oder, oder, oder,
fühlen Sie eine Veränderung?
Bemerk Sie eine Veränderung.
Ja, und nicht immer diese, diese Standardformulierung,
bisschen Variation dahin.
Dann ist es einfach ein bisschen interessanter zu zuhören.
Ja, natürlich.
Gut.
Ich denke, es ist halt für erst den Versuch sehr einfach gleich.
Ja, die Anamnese da für erstens war wirklich gut.
Ich gebe zu, dass nachher der Bericht relativ holzreich war.
Ja, das war,
da waren Sie, da waren Sie nicht so richtig fit auch vom, vom Thema her.
Ja.
Und waren auch unsicher, was jetzt Ihre Diagnose ist,
wobei das, was Sie geschildert haben.
Also, was weiß ich, Vorerkrankungen und,
und was weiß ich, Familienanamnese, Familienstand und so.
Das war okay.
Mit den Zahlen hatten Sie Schwierigkeiten.
Das ist ein Unterschied, ob ich 30 Päckius oder 3 Päckius habe.
Ja.
Und wenn jemand sagt, er ist seit 18 Jahren nicht Raucher,
das ist nicht von 8 bis 10 Jahren oder so.
Ja, okay.
Das muss man vielleicht mal nachfragen.
Zahlen machen ganz vielen Kollegen Schwierigkeiten.
Wobei ich zugebe, dass es in Deutschland auch super schwierig ist.
Ja.
Mit dieser komischen Stellung, dass wir erst die hinteren,
dann die vordere Zahl sagen.
Wir sagen 69, 28, ja, es ist eigentlich genau verkehrt drum.
Ja, man würde ja normal, wenn man, wenn man richtig sagt,
würde man erst den 100er, dann den 10er und dann den 1er sagen.
Ja.
Aber wir sagen das halt komisch.
Ja, Frau Wischmann, darf ich fragen,
ich habe hier notiert und können Sie kontrollieren,
ist das richtig oder nicht?
Ich habe geschrieben als 9 und 69 Jahre alt.
Das war richtig, ja.
Ja, genau.
Auch seit September 1953.
Das ist richtig.
Und 1 Meter 74 Zentimeter.
Ja, richtig.
Und 3 und 8 sind schwer.
Ja, 83 Kilometer.
Genau.
Ja, okay.
Ja, das wäre alles richtig.
Aber bei dem Nichtrauchen oder Rauchen,
da waren die Zahlen eben verkehrt.
Ja.
Und auch bei den Medikamenten.
Gut.
Aber wie gesagt, es ist immer ein bisschen schwierig.